good morning Millennials welcome back to
the toast and happy hump day how you
ding Jack want to hump me want to hump
you I will decline politely just
disgusting thank you for the offer I
know you're surrounded by people who are
desperate to hump you though so I don't
feel bad I am very blessed thank you
forting that out blessed I'm looking at
a gorgeous pillow of dootoo and I know
that he would love to hump you today oh
I think I forgot to I shared on my
Instagram but a little update with Theo
and I totally forgot tell you the second
part cuz I found out yesterday me not me
so you guys know we took Theo to the
doctor his leg was bothering him and of
course we ended up discovering he has a
heart murmur and I freaked out I was
crying crying crying we did a full
EKG and it was probably the best news we
could have gotten it's very moderate he
doesn't even need to go on meds um and
now we just monitor it for the rest of
his life a point might come it could get
worse but now we know about it so we're
going to go every six months to get his
heart checked if it gets worse he goes
on meds if it doesn't he it shouldn't
you know affect his life beautiful this
I knew but then the whole reason we went
for his leg we finally got the answers
too cuz when he got his heart done we
just got him like a whole body x-ray my
poor little angel has a bit of moderate
arthritis that's so Theo though I know
and that's a tough diagnosis know if you
know Theo like arthritis is on brand for
him and his personality I'm surprised I
don't have arthritis like it's kind of
so me yeah well don't like take away
from your boy shine this is his moment
like not to make arthritis about you it
wasn't a great diagnosis because you
know you can't take an antibiotic
arthritis is for Life same for humans
you know it's just it is what it is of
course I made an appointment with the
top arthritis doctor no not the top just
the one that I found um and I'm on it
you know given how scared I was all of
this news well I wish it was I wish
there was no news but I have to have
perspective how much worse this all
could have been yes so I'm so thankful
Theo always in our hearts and I I I
spoke to so many dog moms especially Cal
moms you know the community is small
it's basically just me and Ariel Charis
I spoke to her um her Cavalier has a
heart
murmur I feel good everybody gave me
really great advice and you know what
it's okay it's okay he's going to be
okay it is okay he is going to be okay
we're do strong do
strong we need to make bracelets like
Live Strong that was the craziest time
in America I know but it was so pure it
was like this was this fat and at its
core it was a really great message and
it was for like a really good it's so
true initiative and the bracelets like
we're so ugly and yet the the importance
of the me message in the initiative
outweighed the ugliness of the bracelets
it wasn't like it was this fat and was
like this designer thing it was just
like an ug rubber yellow bracelet that's
similar to what I was going to say is
that what I really liked about the trend
was that like everybody had it but they
were attainable they weren't hard to
come by they weren't expensive they were
only hard to come by in the sense that
they were so popular and exclusive
people were getting like knockoff ones
like do you have an original one or do
you have like one off the street they
weren't expensive if you get your hands
on them but you couldn't get your hands
on them we desperately need to bring
back Liv strong bracelets I can't
remember a time when our country has
ever been more unified than when we were
raising money
for blank a certain kind of canc answer
yes I I feel like it
was like Lance Armstrong yeah it was
giving Lance Armstrong for sure I think
he strong had testicular and I don't
think we were all running around with
bracelets for testicular cancer were we
I don't think so maybe it was just like
Liv strong BL
bracelets cause
meaning yellow silicone wristband that
say Live Strong they were created
specifically for fundraising purposes
for cancer research however as time went
on they went they became very
fashionable and popular I thought you
were going to say as time went on it
turns out none of the proceeds were
helping cancer research that would
happen the documentary that's next but I
think it's cancer in general love the
message such a unifying time for our
country God Bless America we sold 80 we
80 million wristbands generating $100
million in donations for cancer
survivors wait 80 million bracelets only
made $100 million they were like about
$1 they weren't expensive that was icon
no like I'm sorry whoever spearheaded
that campaign deserves like a can lion
award a Nobel Peace Prize can
lion I guess no because of the of the
money rais but it really was about the
marketing whoever started wearing them
and then eventually like other people
you know got crazy and I think they went
off into their different sex like I'm
sure you could get a pink bracelet that
would be for breast cancer like all the
different colors and categories people
kind of broke off into their own
tribes as humans do that's human nature
but never forget the yellow that unified
us where did we buy them I think like
probably the Nike store that's what I
was going to say but was it a Nike
initiative maybe Nike had partnered with
Liv strong and you could probably get
them online if people were shopping
online no like these days you would have
gotten one on Amazon but like where were
we getting Liv strong bracelets I feel
like they would just materialize in
front of youel by Nike and its
advertising agency widen and Kennedy I'm
sure that widen and Kennedy won
something for this at age award yeah wow
throwback throwback what were we
saying do strong do strong
bracelets thank you for tracing back to
the origins of that conversation we have
a great show it's Wednesday we have
three seriously top tier deer toasters
today oo great we also have some pretty
good stories I had actually an abundance
that I Whittle down
I also was going to sit here and recap
my evening at Heidi cl's Halloween party
but you know my ass vlogged it for
patreon so I'll save the exclusive but
can we talk about my costume really
quickly like I know everyone's sick of
me in my four costumes oh yeah cuz
you're that person but I think I saved
the best for last for sure that was your
most intentional costume yeah it was
like the one I planned out for weeks
like literally not me being on like
Poshmark and Etsy what was your second
costume oh no your first was skeleton
then leather dress Travis Fram cheek
crack hole you got
it and I just honestly never in my life
would I have styled my hair like that
like if I ever get my hair done I'm the
most boring client ever like beachy
waves you think they're doing beachy
waves in France like that's
my I'm obsessed with wearing my hair
like that like it kind of looked good
yeah why wouldn't it look good she was a
garous girl it was just of a different
time but like still gorgeous that's what
why it was a good costume because you
know you looked really like someone else
but you still looked pretty like I
didn't have to put on like a big fake
nose you know yeah well you wouldn't be
able to do that because then you would
get canceled more so than being an
actual anti-mite but if you wear a nose
oh oh no oh nose oh
nose um so yeah that was my night I'm
not going to recap it too much cuz there
was some good celebrity uh situation
actually I do want to say one thing that
happened and I got it in the Vlog do you
have celebs in your Vlog yeah yeah cuz
me and Ben went with Taylor and Taylor
lner so it's crawling with celebs your
vlog it's crawling with celebs and after
the party we went to get sushi and when
we got out of the Uber there was a girl
walking down the
street um in costume and she was dressed
with her boyfriend her friend as Shark
Boy and Lava Girl oh my God and you were
with Taylor lner and Taylor saw them
when we were getting out of the car and
just like walked right over to them and
Jackie like they I don't know Jackie
they were geod as they should be they
were shocked he was wearing a wig so he
like ripped the wig off cuz nobody was
able to like tell who he was in the wig
it was honestly the cutest thing ever
they were freaking out no that's not
okay that would be like you running into
Fran dresser in your costume yeah oh my
god do a lot of people dress up as Shark
Boy and Lava Girl honestly I feel like
yeah it's a good Niche costume yeah and
they were just dying screaming taking a
thousand pictures no I'm seriously not
okay for these people so you guys on the
Vlog yeah my dumbass like stopped
recording in the middle and I'm holding
up my phone and I think I'm recording
the whole time and I'm literally not oh
it's okay but I I tried to I got it in
the Vlog so that was just what it's a
really good Vlog I'm so excited to watch
also Ben's story last night was so crazy
of every piece of sushi where did you go
and who allowed him to I couldn't what
was it 40 pieces of sushi on his story
Jackie think about being there being so
hungry and not eating sushi oh but like
was he on his phone the whole time
taking pictures of sushi yeah and did he
ever like was it kind of like a prank
like I'm just going to like spam my feed
with 40 pieces of sushi I wasn't like
thinking so much about Ben's social
media strategy I was thinking about how
absolutely ravenous I was and you know
like it it's Omas which is like that
type of sushi where you sit at the bar
there's no menu like they just give you
piece by piece and you eat what they
give you pece by piece that song is
actually really about the Omas
experience it is and I had to say like
oh no I'm not doing the Omas like can I
have a bowl of rice did you get it yeah
but the thing about omasi is like it's a
really serious like Japanese tradition
like they don't take lightly to your
American [__]
yeah but they do especially the ones in
New York they know kosher style so Ben
couldn't just like sit down and be like
you know [__] it up he had to say like
no shellfish and they no Kosher style so
that they're not bothered by like
they're actually really accommodating
for me like I was trying so hard to be
like you know funny and be like ah and
eventually I think I won the chef over
but he takes his craft really seriously
and someone like me coming and taking a
seat at this table at this bar the
restaurant that seats maybe eight people
they were like get the [__] out of here
[__] why did you go there well so we
were trying to make a dinner reservation
it was a Tuesday it was like 11:00 there
weren't many options a
diner so I that was a a backup option
but like you know this is a group of
people who like enjoy fine dining Omas
or a diner I mean for me it's always
going to be a diner for Ben it's always
going to be Omas I've never had
Omas if you enjoy Sushi and like you
really respect the art of sushi like you
watch the documentary Jiro Dreams of
Sushi you will love it I'm like half of
I like SU Sushi I don't know that like
I've not seen the documentary I respect
Sushi you didn't see jro Dreams of Sushi
no feel like there was a time when that
was like the documentary everyone was
talking about remember yeah but just
added to the list with Avatar things
everyone saw that I didn't for me it's
Wedding Crashers you're wrong for that
and it's not like I have something
against Wedding Crashers it's just I'm
like merely circumstantial like I've
never seen it that's really crazy and
it's so I've seen bits and pieces of it
like definitely I've seen the scene
where you know they crush the
wedding but that's
it okay you should it's you should
remedy that you would like it it's it's
just a no I know it's just a crazy thing
about me that is pretty crazy I'm sure
you've told me that before but it feels
like the first time the very first time
oh god let's not go down this Rabbit
Hole some of our older toasters were
literally their ears were bleeding
listening to us talk about like ' 80s
rock80s we knew it would like as I was
speaking I was I knew we were you knew
you were causing pain I I knew I was
veering into territory I should not be
in it feels like the first time who
sings that song again no I'm okay who
sings it no clue I think oh it was like
a it was a band that we had heard of and
that's what started the whole thing it
was like the revolutionists or something
I thought the fundamentalists I thought
what started it was um The Foreigner
thank you that's what I said Foreigner
but I thought what started it was the
song um and it brings out the woman in
oh wait it's the same
song we have to stop we have to
stop maybe since we keep going to this
place like maybe we were meant to be
here right maybe the universe is
bringing us to this place to begin our
journey journey Journey the band oh
people didn't like that I keep calling
it the band Journey but like I don't
want you guys to think I'm talking about
a journey like oh wait also I meant to
issue a correction Randy Jackson was in
Journey like briefly he played backup he
wasn't like an official member but he's
definitely a part of their history so
you're saying Google got it right yeah
shocking that is shocking okay
cool what were we saying I had one more
thing to say about whatever we were
saying dear toasters Omas my journey at
Heidi's
Halloween Heidi's Halloween did you see
the peacock in IRL I did
not
cool one year I just like want her to go
as like you
know like a nurse yeah from Spirit
Halloween like I think that would be the
only thing that could actually shock
people at this point yeah she I feel
like is getting more and more extreme
every year like last year was the worm
yeah the yearb for that she dresses
herself with like a bunch of clones that
one was I thought was cute um I just
feel like she's on this vicious hamster
wheel where she has to keep outdoing
herself and honestly she needs to reset
she needs to reset like go to Spirit
Halloween off the rack show up see what
happens off the rack
yeah okay well let's get into everything
cuz we have a lot to accomplish today oh
we didn't even talk about toast how well
received that was yesterday was a crazy
long day and toaster was a highlight I
think that's going to go in our Hall of
Fame Ben really made the episode Ben
made the episode I I seriously like I
can't he's deeply unwell and Halloween
is the time where he gets like really
Express that side of himself cuz I'm
always like suppressing it yeah and I'm
glad that he got that out of his system
it was so great on the episode it was so
funny and I loved every minute of being
Jason Kelsey I too enjoyed being Trav I
like being a man once a year I like
being a Man Too honestly it's so chill
it's so
chill even way we were sitting I missed
no I miss crossing my legs you could see
I was like fighting it the whole time by
the way during the ads I was crossing my
legs cuz I could go back to being tury
and then when the ads were over I had to
start mans spreading again mans
spreading is like not that comfortable
yeah but I guess it's cuz we don't have
penises
yet right like next year's Halloween
next Halloween we're going to get really
really we get penises we're going to get
really serious so into character I think
honestly I can't imagine anything more
uncomfortable than having a dick
like who needs that yeah not I Different
Strokes for different folks so I believe
without further a do do to do about do
strong our newest campaign here are the
fast five stories that you need to know
and the fast five stories for do strong
that you need to know are brought to you
by State Farm the State Farm personal
price plan helps you create an
affordable price that's just for you the
plan's all about being personal to you
and your needs so that means that you
are getting the coverage you want a
policy that helps cover what's important
to you and an affordable price just for
you because after all life is just
better when you can personalize your
experiences think about it like this
from your go-to coffee order to your
favorite pair of sweatpants we know you
love to personalize your entire day just
like we do my days these days especially
in my new apartment like I'm on a
routine and if anything comes in and
like messes that up it bothers me
because like our day-to-days are so
personal think about my coffee how long
did it take me to figure out how I like
my coffee a year months yeah and now
here I am and I don't like to mess with
that so I get that's what safe Farm is
all about
personalization just makes everything
better State Farm believes that
insurance should work the same way your
plan your coverage your selections all
can be personalized by you now think
let's take for example Jax and I have
you ever met two girls more similar we
finish each others
sandwiches right even our insurance
needs are so different even though we're
so similar You Know Jack lives in
another state she is a homeowner she is
a car owner like she has a lot of things
going on that I don't have she has you
know depend attendance so State Farm
understands that so like a good neighbor
State Farm is there prices do vary by
state options selected by customer
availability and eligibility may vary
let me try that one more time like a
good neighbor St is there today's
episode is also brought to you by
Mattress Firm when you sleep on the
right mattress everything becomes clear
the right mattress matters and Mattress
Firm will find yours for you this Black
Friday they're having their big sale
where you can win big on Black Friday
shop unbeatable deals at Mattress Firm
before they're gone
uh you can shop in store or online at
mattressfirm.com my mattress yes it's
from Mattress Firm it's a few years old
it's an amazing Condition it's from
temper Pedic that I got at Mattress Firm
and I believe I got it on the Black
Friday sale when I first moved into my
apartment a long time ago and the good
news is that I don't need a new mattress
cuz the one I got for Mattress room is
so stunning but for my second bedroom I
do and I will be taking advantage of
this Black Friday sale for Mattress Firm
in store and online it's important to
support good sleep Habits by optimizing
you and your family's routine around
sleep and around bedtime as sleep
disruptors change due to age location
arrival of new kids a foundation and
routine will help you overcome those
hurdles so with the holidays around the
corner take advantage of this Black
Friday sale you also need to like have a
good mattress you have family coming
over like you need to be able to sleep
soundly because your bed is your
Sanctuary you took the word what did I
just say we finish each other's
sanctuaries so shop the Black Friday
sale from we finish each other's
Sanctuary sorry I was just listening to
that cuz I was trying to you know do
this um so the Black Friday sale is
going on in store and online at mattress
firm.com do not miss it they have
amazing Brands they have amazing bed
accessories like pillows and stuff and
just don't miss out today's episode is
also brought to you by ring conier the
leading luxury Jeweler committed to
designs by women for everyone ring coier
offers accessible on Trend and wearable
everyday fine jewelry for how the Modern
Woman stacks and layers her pieces ring
coner has fine jewelry made to be worn
every day they create custom handcrafted
engagement rings and specialize in
getting you the biggest diamond within
your budget ring concierge makes fine
jewelry at every price point and it's an
internet and celebrity cult favorite
jewelry brand for a reason they're one
of my favorite Brands to follow on
Instagram I feel like I've followed them
for a while now it's just like jewelry
porn and their pieces are fabulous I
like to invest in jewelry that I can
have forever that I don't have to like
take off every time I need to go for a
run you know cuz I'm always going for
runs um and it's it's also great for
giftgiving season so gift giving season
is around the corner whether that's
giving a gift to yourself or to someone
you love or you know a gentle nudge to
the partner in your life you know oh I
hear ring con sege does fabulous Bridal
jewelry oh I hear they get you the best
biggest diamond for your budget just a
gentle nudge that time of year is around
the corner and so make sure you are well
versed in the knowledge of ring con they
have excellent quality really trusted
brand and you can shop there find
jewelry at ringer.com use code toast for
20% off your fine jewelry purchase
that's a big chunk of change toast t o
is the code at ring concierge.com for
20% off your fine jewelry purchase um so
make sure to send a link you know
something you like there holiday season
around the corner send the link send the
code too send the code thank you Claudia
you're
welcome our first story New Flame of
Thrones Sophie Turner has moved on from
Joe Jonas as she snogs a UK Aristocrat
who has just ditched his Royal ex oh I'm
obsessed yeah so Sophie Turner shared a
tender kiss with one of Britain's most
eligible bachelors who has just ditched
a real life Princess Sophie wrapped her
arms around Aristocrat perig green
Pearson whose family are said to be
worth 224 million pounds as he
courteously removed what's the
conversion let me just it's pretty it's
almost one to one so I think it's a
little more dollars but it's always
changing these days the dollar is crap
right pounds doar crap
dollars I just need to see it's not 272
272 um he removed his hat to snog her in
Paris and then they reunited later at
the Rugby World Cup where she presented
the trophy to the Rugby World Cup
looking amazing looking so gorgeous in a
in such a cool gorgeous outfit also
worth noting parag green is the air of
the fourth by count cowr and he split
from King Charles's goddaughter model
princess Maria Olympia of Greece and
Denmark 27 in
sepia okay I needed to just like look up
a picture of this man so I could
visualize I didn't hear this story so
you're delivering this news to me in
real time the sun go to the sun they
have the photo of them kissing on the
street in Paris and the photo of the
ex-girlfriend photo from
rugby and they have the
team I'm obsessed with this I feel
like remember how we always say like
when Joe Jonas was dating Gigi ad it was
like very hard for him to like top that
yeah and he ended up with Sophie Turner
and honestly like crushed it and same
goes now for sopie Turner like the Jonas
brothers are really like America
sweetheart they're so famous where do
you go from there honestly like it's
hard you really do have to Pivot like
and pivot she did pivot she did this is
a a wonderful pivot we know she wants to
be spending time in the UK nothing like
a a homegrown boy okay I'm looking at
these photos let me say I love what
she's wearing to this rugby rugby love
what she's wearing she's got great style
obsessed oh his ex-girlfriend was King
Charles's goddaughter I said that but oh
I'm sorry I was looking for pictures and
I wasn't listening she's so like classic
British Aristocrat looking girl she
looks like the type of girl who dated
Prince Harry Greek and Denmark
Aristocrat yeah obsessed um he's very
handsome he's not like so hot which I
think is good nobody wants to date
someone who's like so hot then you
always have to be just like looking over
your shoulder at you know what Harlot is
trying to steal your man but for sure
you still need to look over your
shoulder they want to steal your
Aristocrat too 100% I'm obsessed with
this
situation AR aristocracy is exactly what
Sophie needed for real like she's a
British queen she's the queen of the
north yeah and I love yeah I feel like
that's that's her vibe I'm sure he like
gets down she likes to have a good time
they can you know travel the world go to
the events have a good time like he's on
her level like there's nowhere that like
he gets invited to that they wouldn't be
more than happy to have her at you know
yeah and and I'm sure like same goes for
him like there's nowhere he can't get
into it's like it's like that that Tik
Tok do you know who my father is right
right when I bu's
Club I am so happy I also do feel like
someone could say like this is
relatively quick I don't [__] care I
feel like when it's so contentious and
it was I'm sorry you can't convince me
with like the media like you're the love
you had is gone you are so ready to be
loved and moved on I'm obsessed does
this guy have kids I don't think so I
don't think he's ever been married he's
29 so probably not he's probably like
you know a little bit Bachelor bachelor
boy but I feel like he would give it all
up for Sophie no I'm so happy like I
love this I'm sure people will be like
she's moving on too quickly like I agree
with you I don't care who knows how
miserable they were for how long and
like she's young like get back out there
yeah no like what we should be wasting
our lives being mized find some joyy in
your life and it's like even if this
isn't like her next relationship it
might be soon for a relationship just
cuz you need to grieve and everything
like why can't you have fun why can't
you enjoy life uh that's a good question
whatever happened to fun love I love
this and she's just so Chic and like
these types of events like you know
other celebrities going to like the
World Cup of rugby like it's so elevated
yeah it
is and I guess we just have to wait and
see who Joe dates I feel like
he's like not going to date someone for
a while yeah but I think he'll impress
with whoever he like who he dates next
he has nice taste in the ladies he does
he does that's very true they all do
they all do everyone does cuz women are
wonderful it's so
true so
true uh so congrats Sophie we will be
keeping a close eye on these two I feel
like it's been so long since you told me
something on the toast like I genuinely
had no idea about I love that for us
like I hadn't even heard I love that
breaking news for tury me too and maybe
for some other people yeah look up these
pics the sun has the pick they're like
at the train station smooching love yeah
okay let's get into our next story you
ready mhm there's been some Fallout from
this variety Bravo article that came out
I saw two notable Things First Bethany
Frankle and Ebony K Williams are kind of
um beefing beefing Bethany clapped back
at ebony for telling her to [__] off
with a screenshot of a conversation from
three years ago so in response to the
Variety article and um Bethany you know
championing the The Real Housewives and
unionizing whatever um Bethany had said
um she expressed negative opinion about
the real reality stars effort sorry
ebony said you think I'm going to get
let some white girls speak for me with
my experience with a billion dollar
Corporation right they were referring to
this lawsuit and then Bethany's like
representing a lot of people and Ebony
was asked like are you a part of this
and she's like uh no right so then
Bethany posted a screenshot of her DMS
with ebony she wrote in response to
ebony K Williams telling me to [__] off
and it was a message from ebony from
June 2020 saying we met on a private
flight from Palm Beach to New York City
a couple of years ago just thank you
thanking you for consistently using your
platform for tangible change and then
Bethany responded when she saw it in
August 2022 wow I never saw this thanks
and I'm sorry so late so I guess it's
Bethany saying like oh you didn't want
me to [__] off then but now I'll [__]
you know like um I don't think that
screenshot really proves anything it
just proves like she was once a a fan
but she's not being a like if the
message had said like oh my God can't
believe I Met You Like Love here's the
picture we took like I don't think it's
like a damning thing actually I think
what ebony said is like a very um
respectful and nice compliment like of
all the things someone could say to
Bethany like to to commment her on her
charity is so it's such a nice thing
yeah so I don't really feel like this
message proves anything other than like
ebony being a nice girl yeah I think it
just proves that at one point like ebony
had respect for Bethany and now she's
telling her to [__] off yeah and I'm
sure ebony now has a lot more experience
with Bethany you think yeah what would
their experience have been like I feel
like the way I don't know when I when I
hear about like things Bethany said
about the new roon women it's like so I
am sure at the time I don't remember I'm
sure when when ebony came on the show
I'm sure Bethany like wasn't you know
receptive woman supporting woman Queen
you know understood okay like I don't
Ebony's not a mean person I don't think
ebony would say something about Bethany
unless she had a reason to dislike her
honestly yeah or she just doesn't want
to be a part of whatever Bethany's got
cooking for whatever reason like she she
wants to do her own thing like she's not
going to have Bethy speak for her like
plus as we said like Bethany did get so
so much from the show she like she's not
in the same position as the people that
she's proclaiming to want to Champion
it's true and also I think with her own
with her Union and her lawsuit I think a
lot of people feel like Bethany her
heart is definitely in the right place
but she might have some ulterior motives
and like her being the face of the
movement so maybe Ebony's like no if I
have my own experience like I'm going to
Champion that on my own not under
someone's umbrella maybe that's what she
was saying yeah but a [__] off is a
little strong agreed agreed but
sometimes you know you say things in a
strong way and no and I know if somebody
ever transcribed something I said yeah
it comes off harer it does I'm always
like oh that [__] but I'm not calling
that person a bit I'm like oh that [__]
you know yeah or it can be like oh [__]
off with that not like [__] off yeah so
verbal transcriptions honestly do nobody
any favors I
agree but then the second part of the
variety thing that I think is bigger
news Rona yeah Ramona has been dropped
from Bravo conon after using a partial
racial slur in a text to a page six
reporter
so Ramona as we discussed on the show
when the Variety article came out there
was a allegation that there was a hot
cheet um that had that said that Ramona
used the nword and then Ramona texted a
page six reporter a screenshot of a page
six article the screenshot that said
this the real estate real estate burer
comment about Rooney not needing black
people reportedly made producers hot
sheet a post-filming document that
recounts on camera dialogue and action
in detail and Ramona texted that to the
reporter and said this never was on the
hot sheet if you read Vanity Fair
article please remove And the reporter
wrote back that was changed yesterday
then so Ramona was texting with the page
six reporter the page six reporter was
kind of recapping writing other stories
for page six about the vanity FOH and
they and they they clearly Miss
represented what the Vanity Fair article
said so Ramona was just like clearing
her name and then Ramona said this is
also upsetting and the word I used was
quote
nword
like wait what this is going to be a
very hard story right right right she
said I used the word nword
like she she said it no the N like
nword she she wrote n w r d n w o r d
That's the word she
used not not the
slur so Ramona
texted n w r d to the page six yes and
she said that's what she said when when
the article said oh oh oh say she never
used the real word she just said quote
and we say real word and yeah perfect
yeah this is hard this is hard so Ramona
is telling the page six person I never
used real word the word I used was nword
and then she goes not N Dash g dot dot
dot dot
dot so the N Rona has got to be stopped
so the n-g is the partial slur that
Ramona used that's gotten her Dro from
bravocon honestly I highly doubt it was
just this it's the whole thing like I
don't know if they would have dropped
her I think they would have dropped her
just
anyways but like but why would the this
is my issue with all of this it's like
they drop her now even though they had
her at the last Bravo con when this had
already been done they knew this was
done this is not new information to
anyone there it's just about like how
they look to the public like what do you
actually [__] stand for no that's so
true it's so true because ebony said and
in the article like this whole thing
happened happened in like 2021 yeah so
it's years we had heard like rumors
about it there was an investigation and
they didn't feel compelled to do
anything out of you know the goodness of
their heart or out of righteousness or
out of what they felt was right and
wrong now it came out in Vanity Fair
they still didn't even do anything and
then this text message which if if
everything in the vanity far article is
true this text message is small in the
grand scheme of thing right like this
text and is going to be what's she's
getting asked for after all the other
allegations like it just it's very but
that's so Bravo like we say this all the
time about things happen years before
and it's not until like they get some
heat even though they knew about these
things like Endor like things were
proceeded as Rona was on Ultimate girls
trip like they don't really care it's
just about public perception which is
lame
yeah so so I guess this is like really
probably the final straw for Ramona with
the network but I feel like she was
already done with the network both like
there's not really a job for her cuz
they don't they're not doing roony
Legacy I guess she was doing the
ultimate girls trips but she's also said
she's like done with it she's in a great
place and she's just living her life
yeah but if she was going to Bravo con
like that's the thing with Bravo con
really created like another dimension of
Bravo Liberties of people who aren't on
the air but who still will come to Bravo
Bravo con maybe be on watch Happens live
like the shots of sunset people were at
Bravo con last year and the show had
been canceled you get paid to go to
Bravo con I don't think so I don't think
so either but I feel like but you get an
opportunity to do like a a thing at your
at a booth for your brand so you can
sell t-shirts your merch so you make
money but also if you went on housewives
for fame like that's probably the most
famous you'll ever feel that's like what
we talked about the this week when the
article came out the housewife who said
like how will I ever be happier than
this cuz she was just like showered with
love and fame and your name is being
chanted yeah yeah so I do feel like this
has to be sort of the end of the road
for Ramona's relationship with Bravo in
any
capacity it's just
so weak from Bravo that it's because of
this based on everything else that that
was said and she still had a
relationship with them like and it was
it was like buried yeah but if it if
they stand so against us and where were
where were you in it happen were you
then I also feel like this um article
like yes we're talking about the Fallout
and like the backlash but I don't really
feel like it moved the needle that much
I don't think people were really shocked
by anything in it yeah and I don't think
they really care yeah I haven't really
heard much aside from like what the two
things I just shared but that's also me
seeking it out for stories today like I
really didn't hear about it organically
on my own
right so that's what's going on in the
Bravo world are you excited for Bravo
conon I am I actually like leave really
soon I need to get outfits and I'm lit
you should rewear what you wore for
Halloween last night like as a regular
outfit for life really yeah you looked
great okay like France she had style had
flare she was there that's how became
shenan but she also like like had
eternally good Style Style yeah she was
kind of
Timeless free idea Love Actually there's
more going on in the Bravo world oh
summer House's star Lindsay hubard has
broken her Silence about her humiliating
split from Carl raty okay so Lindsay sat
down for an interview with US Weekly and
is to mentioning it all I feel like she
could have gotten like a bigger
exclusive you know yeah I wonder um
she was at a rooftop and Lou I don't
know she weekly there's some pics she
looks great and she's talking about how
she's been doing since the split she
said the first month she allowed herself
to feel all of the feelings go through
the sadness the pain the Whiplash she
said I process things by talking about
my emotions and my friends allowed me
that space she said the way that car
handled everything was such an absolute
betrayal of my trust and when that
happens it makes it easier to pick
yourself up and put yourself out there
again yeah I get that cuz it's like oh
I'm so done with this person they're not
the person I thought they were she also
said she had no idea this was coming she
said every couple has normal arguments
but nothing that would have been so
drastic as to break up it was literally
the last two weeks of Summer that his
demeanor and tone changed there was a
lot of combativeness and aggression on
his end and I was very confused she said
planning the wedding was high stress
plus we were filming all summer I think
people gotten his ear but it's not
normal to call off a wedding because you
had a couple of AR arguments she said
the breakup was absolutely humiliating
it would have been one thing if the
conversation happened over the summer
during the normal filming schedule but
for Carl to call up producers and then
set up cameras and manipulate me into
sitting down so he could break up with
me after we'd already wrapped is scary
the whole world found out within 30
minutes of me she said she had the most
amazing group of girlfriends who rallied
around her and supported her including
Danielle they're very close again but I
think also some of the other girls in
the summer house she said other girls
were there for her
um and I don't know if everything she's
saying is true like then that's crazy
really are two sides to every story and
like I I I have such a hard time seeing
this being the reality where like one
day he wakes up calls a camera crew and
breaks up with her you know it's like
other things had to have happened well
she said it was two weeks I think they
were arguing a lot which is pretty
normal for um fiance 3 months before a
wedding and maybe just to one person
it's like okay this is a normal amount
of pre-wedding arguing and we're
destined to be together and for another
person it's like this means no yeah this
means we shouldn't be together really I
was actually really shocked when they
broke up more shocked than them getting
together and getting engaged everybody
was so shocked they we're moving so
quick like none of that shocked me this
shocked me yeah me too it still shocks
me and I feel like I won't be able
to come to terms with it until I watch
the season 100% like right now I'm
reading this I'm being like get back
together no it's literally never going
to happen no but once I watch the season
I'm going to be like like never that's
how I feel about every like relationship
that at one point I loved like LA and
Randall now
G yeah that's such a good point I um I
wonder what it'll be like for them at
bravocon like they're still like
co-workers yeah and she was also saying
like it's hard because he was her best
friend like she not only lost her fiance
but like that friendship is done no and
yeah she like really isolated herself
too everyone sort of they isolated
themselves but everybody kind of like
pushed them away yes they were on an
island of just them two and now they
don't even have each other I'm glad
she's friends with Danielle again and I
feel like annoyed because them breaking
up kind of validates everything Danielle
was feeling but I stand by like nobody
has ever acted crazier or worse or has
been more wrong than Danielle on this
season of Summer House agreed and
Lindsay said um in this interview that
she still doesn't think they went too
fast because when you create a
friendship that that we had over eight
years you know this person you know
their quirks flaws and boundaries you
bypass that getting to know you face so
I agree like something
happened y that summer and maybe we'll
see um you're saying It Happened One
Summer It Happened One Summer she said
she gave the ring to her Jeweler to sell
she needs to make up for all the lost
money on the wedding like she's just
being like real as [__] that's real as
[__] that she kept the ring I don't know
well he broke up with her so yeah [__]
you I feel like the only really
appropriate time to give to give the
ring back is like if you're calling it
off if you're calling it off and like
this guy's so in love with you and it's
just like the wrong thing to do yeah or
like if it's a heirloom yeah yeah yeah
she's going to be writing a book too
love that for her monetized girl
capitalize on the moment yeah so it's a
very extensive interview check it out in
US Weekly no stone left unturned no
stone left unturned are you ready for
our next story mhm it's our fourth story
I'm ready and you feel ready yep cuz
speaking of can Lion's Awards one of the
best ads I've ever seen has just come
out Mean Girls cast has reunited for an
epic Walmart March shopping spot for
Black Friday I don't know I watched this
ad this morning caudia it looks like the
Mean Girl sequel that's coming out it
was so good and well written everyone's
in it except for Regina of course it it
yeah but we knew that she like doesn't
really [__] with them but uh Lindsay
Lohan amenda safreed Lacy shaber Daniel
franies who's Damian and rajie serendra
whose Kevin G is in it and they all have
like their children okay I'm watching it
be quiet yeah watch it oh it's 2 minutes
long it's worth it you're not going to
want it to
end oh those
kids with the weather there's a it's
already
Wednesday this wasn't regular shopping
this was deal shopping oh this is good
this is
good Kevin J Kevin counselor I was still
getting schooled GRL huh what's
GRL it's nothing man I'm dead beet make
fetch happen Mom it's still not going to
happen we were a school
obsessed if you have Walmart plus you
will okay I will finish watching it
later nobody needs to watch me watch the
whole thing but I love first of all high
production value I cannot believe Regina
wasn't in it that's really losery of her
I'm sorry like I'm sorry it's not like
everyone in the crew is a big loser like
Lindsay Lohan Amanda Amanda seed like
come on do better Rael do better she
probably didn't expect that it would be
this good cuz most things aren
especially if it's like I don't know the
Walmart writers writing a commercial for
mean girls but like that looks like a
premise for the next movie it's like
Gretchen's daughter you need to like
keep watching and then also what's
exciting is they're going to keep
releasing new commercials every
Wednesday until their Black Friday sale
so oh by the way these girls are getting
paid like paid it's Walmart it's
multiple ads it's the usage of like you
know the me girls old but I feel like
the writing was so good and the premise
was so good and they are doing a sequel
I wonder if this is the concept it's
like Gretchen's daughter is the new
regina Katie is K being the guidance
counselor is the best thing like that
was her sto story arc like who who
better to guide the kids than somebody
who was so misguided you know yeah no
and like Gretchen's like kids doing Tik
Tock dance and she's like filming them
it's really
Perfection oh I love that I'm I can't
get past the Rachel mcadam's thing it's
so losery I'm sorry yeah and it's losery
especially that it's so good and she's
not a part of it yeah no and I'm sorry
like Amanda I I would argue Amanda sea
freed is more
highbrow actress like out of the two of
them I think I would I would only say no
because like Rachel has made me feel
this way by not by abstaining right and
I guess like she wasn't an Oscar
nominated film
Spotlight but I feel like Amanda caed
goes to the Oscars I she did Elizabeth
Holmes
yeah maybe she doesn't go to the Oscars
we've we've been down this road before
we have of like looking up what Amanda
safed has been in and and assessing
whether or not she's a big
star she's a big star no no like a
A-list like fancy
fancy I just like
honestly I love this it's so well done I
agree I can't wait to watch the whole
thing but but it it makes me look at
Rachel McAdams differently it does like
I'm sorry yeah but it also reminds me
towards the end of Mean Girls when like
the three of them were hanging out
without her mhm and she kind of like
went and she became like a field hockey
player maybe she's you know at the
Olympics oh maybe that's next
Wednesday she should jump in she should
jump it's not too late she'll probably
get a couple
Mill it probably is too late I believe
they've all been filmed but she could do
like something like Samantha Jones
calling in on the phone remote yeah
remote where she's like a field hockey
coach for her daughter soccer team and
they're traveling the
world I love being a field hocky coach
for a soccer team if anyone could do it
it's Regina George yeah so that's some
exciting ad news yeah that's cute it's
nice when companies like make waves not
in the Super Bowl yeah also you need to
keep watching because it's also such a
good ad for their Black Friday sale
which starts on Wednesday I know
everything about Walmart deals by the
way it's Black Friday season did you see
that Meme going around like hey stores
we don't need any more flat screen TVs
do the
groceries yeah it's just so true Kathy
Hilton posted that Meme that's why I saw
it that's really funny and really true
do like we need a do eggs do eggs you
know yeah I made some um egg bites
yesterday I'm sure you saw I saw oh did
you get any trick-or-treaters uh a few
did you I got I got two and Ben I was in
the bath for one of them so Ben answered
the door I missed one of them how was
the experience honestly extremely
unpleasant why because I just ate all
the candy yeah that's the hard part I
didn't even have a good selection
because the store was out of like the
mixed bags cuz I was late so what did
you get I got like a bag of mini Crunch
bars mini Hershey bars and mini Snickers
so I only had three different types
Crunch
bars I was limited people like them I
don't no the thing is they get away with
a lot because you think that they're
like good and crunchy and chocolatey but
they suck no let me tell you why they
get away with a lot because they're a
distant cousin of the bunch of crunch
and bunch of crunch is
Stellar bunch of crunch coattails a
100% I feel like Crunch bars who's
actually buying them they only ever show
up yeah especially the big ones nobody
seeks out a Crunch bar so I ate a lot of
candy this Halloween and not even good
candy that's the the worst like if I had
eat eaten like good milky ways like good
[__] I would have felt like all right
you know what I ate a [__] ton of candy
but at least I enjoyed myself I was like
hating myself eating these Crunch bars
yeah I understand I'm sorry tury tail is
old this time are you ready for well in
your opinion when there's a big bowl of
mixed candy like what do you go for
what's the number one like what are you
always looking for I always Twix is my
number one and it's also very ubiquitous
it's pretty much in every Bowl so I'll
always go for the Twix I also love
Almond Joy ew and like a Milk
Dud I feel like there's no better candy
like Milky Way is the number one candy
and I feel like nobody agrees with me I
like I think a lot of people agree with
you I will never really electively eat a
Milky Way or a Snickers until they're
the last ones and then I would eat the
Snickers first and then the Milky wave
wow but it's always Twix first for me
how Twix is always last for me have you
ever seen the milky ways that are in the
yellow packaging and it's just caramel
it's like extra caramel no
so good also like a pack of M&M's I
would grab
always I like Peppermint
Patty that's like a healthy candy do you
know what I mean Almond Joy and York
like those are like that's like toxic
diet almond mom type of [__] no Three
Musketeers
is okay I hear you but I want to say
they're so good I was going to say I
like a Three Musketeers but they're
since they're so Airy they are a little
lessor
and back to the Milky Way so of course
there's the tiny little fun size yeah
then there's the smaller snack size that
is just the perfect size candy yeah Fun
Size like honestly I love a Milky Way I
don't think I could really finish the
big one like seriously I need like three
glasses of milk like it's so dry yeah
also but then I feel like Milky Ways
they kind of have a surplus of Milky Way
midnights which are not good I'm so glad
you're talking about the Milky Way
midnights cuz we need to [__] talk
about it like just stop making them
nobody's ever electively going for a
Milky Way Midnight over a Milky Way
regular stop making them it's basically
just I don't even by the way I've never
even had one it's just a Milky Way of
dark chocolate it's midnights and it's
wrong midnight it's
disgusting uh who Mars that's probably
the company stop stop Milky Way
midnights are an industry plant yeah
they're [__] everywhere nobody's
actually buying them I know that my bowl
downstairs is only the Milky we
midnights are left because nobody wanted
them I can't believe we've had this
conversation cuz I'm also always going
to go first for a Kit
Kat obsessed that we can agree on that I
think everybody can agree on we'll meet
at the Kit Kats have you ever been to uh
Hershey Park like Hershey World the
factory no have you yeah oh cuz I think
you went to a camp where they took you
but I didn't go to that camp it's one of
the most Magic Magical places on Earth
like Disney adults I'll never understand
Hershey adults I understand you Hershey
adults greater than 100%
H okay now it's time for our fifth and
final story which was a a tury choice oh
I'm excited to talk about it the fifth
and final story that was a tur's choice
is brought to you by 9 West did you know
that no I didn't The Nine West
fabulosity is real sorry I just messed
it up 9 West is one of the world's most
recognized Brands they Define Timeless
feminine style and they Translate to key
trends they translate key trends into
wearable and attainable Styles so I feel
like 9 West is one of those Brands we've
known forever and it's just like always
really solid for shoes of course but
they also carry a bunch of other
different things but of course we all
know them for shoes they are fashionable
on brand and culturally relevant they
Embrace Sisterhood they Inspire women
everywhere to Take On The World in style
so of course we know their Footwear
collections which are fabulous but they
also carry apparel and accessories that
are all so comfortable so stylish and
made really well cuz they've got that 9
West stamp of approval you know mhm 9
West also makes shopping for Trends a
lot easier with their needed now edit
which is also known as the nine edit
they highlight key trends like western
style boots loafers and more I feel like
boot trends at least for me like with
Tik Tok and stuff like it's really hard
to keep up but 9 West does the work for
you so you're on Trends not late I'm
like always late to Trends it's so
embarrassing um but 9 West like really
keeps me on my toes literally having me
on Trend in style all season long for
the perfect going out you you can shop
their F collection the f stands for
Fierce and feminine so visit
ninewest.com and use code toast at
checkout for 15% off your purchase
that's n NE not the number
ninewest.com use code toast for 15% off
your first order today's episode is also
brought to you by kiwico unwrap
inspiration with super fun science
technology and art projects for your
kids with kiwi Co with nine different
subscription options for kids of all
ages and subjects there's something for
everyone when you give kiwo it's so much
more than just a box of toys it's the
gift of Discovery through Hands-On
experiences giving kids the tools to
learn about topics that they love from
dinosaurs to rocket ships so Ki C
delivers seriously fun Hands-On projects
that inspire a lifelong love of learning
their projects spark creative confidence
for ongoing tinkering and
experimentation sure you can buy a robot
but isn't it way more fun to build one
and something I have learned about
spending so much time with kids is like
a toy is not enough you know you need to
keep their attention for more than five
minutes and a toy is just not going to
accomplish that kiwico their crates come
you build you learn you touch it's just
so many different things it's an
afternoon full of fun for you and for
the kids the day that the Kiwi Co box
arrives is going to start being your
kids's favorite day of the month they're
something for kids of all ages from
infants and preschoolers to teens and
Beyond there's no commitment with the
subscription so you can pause or cancel
at any time and they offer gifts with
Rich activities for kids of all ages
give your kids the tools to learn new
skills build new experiences and make
new connections to the broader World
kwio projects are designed by a team of
Educators makers engineers and Rocket
scientists they are real engineering
science in projects with high quality
materials so discover Hands-On fun with
kiwi Co get your first month free on any
crate line at kiwico.com toast that's
your first month free at K
iw. com toast kiwico.com
toast thank you turty you're welcome our
fifth and final story tury's Choice it's
a tur's
choice door Dash now warns you it's a
tur's choice choice choice it's a
choice door Dash now warns you that your
food might get cold if you don't tip
orders without tips included ahead of
time look less lucrative to drivers
meaning you might be waiting longer so
doores has added a popup in its app this
week warning customers that orders with
no tip might take longer to get
delivered the popup says orders with no
T tip might take longer to get delivered
are you sure you want to continue
Dashers can pick and choose which orders
they want to do orders that take longer
to be accepted by Dash asers tend to
result in slower delivery the move of
course if I was a door Dasher I wouldn't
even [__] accept that one right the
move appears to be an effort by door
Dash to show customers that drivers are
likely going to prioritize more
profitable work I mean
duh no I was shocked when I found out
that there on certain apps you can place
your order put in a tip and then after
the order is delivered you can change
the tip to zero that's what people do to
get their things prioritized like
seriously those people should be banned
from the app they should you should get
like a few chances to be able to do that
like what if your delivery experience
was actually crap um but if you do that
like more than a certain amount of times
in a certain period of time like you
should be banned from the app 100% 100%
because you know what ordering food is a
privilege so if you are going to be
placing an order for delivery you know
that's more expensive than cooking at
home you have to be prepared to tip your
driver like I'm sorry you are vile you
are disgusting and don't [__] do it
yeah it shouldn't even be an option by
the way like the absolute minimum that
they charge you okay like if you want to
be be really cheap like 5% but there
should be there you shouldn't even be
allowed on any of these apps to do 0%
tip yeah so and honestly more of the app
should be doing this I feel like a lot
of these apps whether it's like for like
uber rides or delivery like they should
have a more concerted effort to get
their R their drivers whether it be for
deliveries or just for you know
trips there should be more of a an
effort on the platform to make
it impossible to not do a tip yeah for
sure I mean it goes back to this bigger
question about tipping in general like
tipping culture that's a different thing
especially in this country is like out
of control like people come here from
other countries and they don't tip it
like weight service in other countries
because it's baked into the cost of
whatever you're doing and so it's a
question of like should the platform
charge more and pay the drivers
more okay or is it on people to tip I
mean I I I'm not one of these people
who's doing zero doll tip so I like but
I feel for the people who aren't getting
tipped should it be on the platforms to
pay their workers we live we live in an
insane tipping culture I'm not I don't
think that this refers to that because
this is a Scara where a person deserves
to be tipped you went grocery shopping
you did all the heavy lifting you
deserve a
tip the joke running joke where they
flip the iPad around after somebody
brings you a cup of water like that
isn't saying tipping culture has gotten
so far out of control but there are
actual tasks especially with all these
apps when somebody does like a job for
you but do you think that it should be
on the app like instacart like the tip
is baked into the instacart fee which
should be more that way no one gets
screwed wait say that again like if
instacart charged more for their
services so that it and it went and and
then they just paid a livable wage to
their drivers I don't know because
things like instacart somebody doing
grocery shopping for you like that's
that's like a typal thing you know like
there I I can't explain it it's
like yeah to me that's like a typal job
but I guess a world in which like
restaurants paid all their staff a nice
Hefty sum salary and you don't tip up
like to me that makes sense but somebody
doing your grocery shopping for you
that's like a like they're doing you a
favor almost like you tip someone who's
doing you a favor yeah but I feel like
you could always still add tip add more
tip but then it makes it so that if the
person got no tip which is so crazy to
do no [__] tip and that makes it so
even if they did get zero tip like they
still got paid decently for the work if
you can't afford to tip then you
shouldn't be ordering yeah it's not
right no it's not no I don't know what
the answer is for tip culture honestly
like I there are parts that are like so
crazy the arguments can be made um for
both both ways yeah but then it's like
but then when the company winds up
charging you more they wind up taking
more
the thing about the tip is that 100% of
it goes to the person so even it's
really the companies are corrupt yeah
even if instacart was like okay we're
going to charge you a 15% service fee
and that's going to be the tip so don't
worry about tipping like would they give
the whole 15% to the driver probably not
nah
no it's by the way a big portion of the
fault goes on the companies yes 100% the
company's going to company you know
right right we still have to be decent
human beings right
yeah know I see [__] like this all the
time like um dash cam or a ring doorbell
footage of like somebody like a a door
Dash driver coming back and being like
you took my tip away I literally carried
like cases of water for you like it's
disgusting it's
disgusting taking the tip away is so
crazy at least if you're going to do
zero then submit it as zero and and see
if anybody bit
Yeah you get what you pay for yeah
no more more of these types of companies
should be doing more things like this
like oh you're not going to tip that's
fine good luck getting someone to agree
to take your your task on yeah and you
really shouldn't be able to edit the tip
down you should be able to edit it up
without like tangible proof like no it's
like if they went and they picked out
all rotten berries and bright you know
what I mean like right or like cracked
all your eggs right like you should be
able to send
pictures and and you can bring your chip
down but like it shouldn't be so easy no
even like if somebody like gets the
wrong thing for me like I never bring
the tip down like I still tried it I
still tried no it would have to be like
seriously an intentionally horrible
experience where it took hours all my
berries had mold on them they bought but
even if my products were bad I would ask
for a refund from the store but I
wouldn't take someone's tip away I'm
nobody intentionally goes out of their
way to hurt me via groceries you know I
get a refund on the product which they
typically do yes
yeah no people like are really
disgusting yeah no this is why we can't
have nice things it is a privilege to
order food yep or groceries and you have
to be prepared to pay the piper y all
right are you ready for tear toasters
I'm really excited about them I am okay
deer toasters is our weekly advice
segment where we do three submissions
you can email us dear toaster gmail.com
or you can go to our website the toast
podcast.com there's a submission box
they're both totally Anonymous we do
three submissions a week we just try to
help the girlies you know with what
they're going through and I think today
will be no different ready
mhm hey girlies I think I did something
really bad am I the [__] I created a
hinge for my brother without him knowing
he is in a relationship no one likes the
girl not even my brother he's too nice
and doesn't want to hurt her feelings
and break up with her he's tried a few
times but she cries and he chickens out
last year the girlfriend asked to move
in with him to save money on rent she's
also a bartender and he lives closer to
where she works our parents and friends
do not like her personality and they
don't think she's very friendly or fun
to be around I made the hinge for him to
see if there are any better options out
there for him I'm also hoping one of her
friends finds the hinge and it causes a
fight between them I know this is wrong
but my fear of having this girl in my
life and family is scarier
help I don't think it's that bad I mean
he needs to man up really you I know
like grow up yeah like you can't like do
everything for him if he wants to be in
a miserable relationship like because
he's too chicken [__] to break up with
her like then this is what he deserves
like you people have to make their bed
and lie in it really yeah and like I'm
all for helping people but like if
somebody can't even help themselves like
okay but I know it's your brother like
you would sooner live with a person who
like makes you unhappy because you're
like can't break up with them like
seriously grow up you would sooner pay
their rent instead of having an
uncomfortable conversation grow the [__]
up even though you'd rather live an
uncomfortable life than have an
uncomfortable conversation grow up like
sorry so I don't really care what you do
if you if you overstep if you under step
like he has to figure this out for
himself yeah no I think you would be
doing him more of a service by telling
him to grow a pair than doing everything
for him but I understand like for a
sibling you want to do everything for
them and you could show him like girls
on hinge that he could be but he needs
to help himself like you can't live this
life for him I believe it was the great
Gracie L freebush who once said people
care about people that care about
themselves that's an interesting quote
yeah no it was uh it she says it at the
beginning and it's actually like it was
supposed to be emblematic of how far
Gracie had fallen from herself like
people she was basically saying like you
need to take care of like your looks and
stuff because people care about people
who care about themselves got it and it
was really um and then that little girl
she told her to repeated it to her at
the end of the movie and Gracie's like I
don't know about that oh okay so it's
like bad advice yeah no it was it was
this that quote is kind of the The
Invisible String of the home whole film
that really highlights how far Gracie
like she fell into pageant culture and
she started caring about the wrong
things but I just feel like that makes
the movie seem like it's bad I'm not I'm
not here for the genes for the evolution
of the quote also it could be spun in a
more positive way like people care about
people who care about like self-care you
know I want to care about someone who
has worked on
themsel yeah no you could spin the the
quote for sure spun so yeah you're not
doing anything like crazy wrong because
this relationship obviously is moronic
however like if you really want to help
your brother like you can lead a fish to
water what's you can lead a horse to
water but you can't make him drink
right yeah no that wasn't really the
quote I was saying the quote I was
saying teach a man no no no you're right
you're right what's the one with fishing
yeah if you uh catch like buy a man of
fish he'll eat for a day if you teach a
man to fish he will eat for a lifetime
that but that's not doesn't apply here
the first one did no I think the second
one applies better um like you could do
all the work for him like get him the
girlfriend do great or you could teach
him how to be a normal human being and
the whole rest of his life you you won't
have to keep doing this for into water
but you can't make him drink Claud no I
like the fish one she's doing too much
for him and she's not doing the right
thing sound off in the comments which
limeric applies I think my limeric is
better for real I hope people see that
they're both yours the I'm telling you
trust your instinct no I hope people see
that the second one is better for real
okay ready the second one is a better
limmerick in general no I think it is a
better life lesson but the first one
applies more heavily to this situation I
don't agree sound up in the comments All
Right Next upep way to resolve conflict
sound off in the comments
yeah love you guys so much I'm a lonely
recent college grad listening to you
guys makes me feel like I'm with my
friends my boyfriend and I have been
together for a while he's a total P jom
but last night I discovered a red flag
he doesn't like body hair I'm a very
hairy girl and he touched my leg last
night night and pointed out my leg hair
and also the hair in other places I had
when we were hooking up the night before
I'm not one of those girls who doesn't
shave this was like after 4 days of not
shaving and my hair just grows fast the
next day I asked him if body hair
bothers him and he said yes and I said
hypothetically if I sto shaving he said
we would need to have a serious talk
this is so off-putting to me it just
seems immature that he's turned off by
body hair is this a cause for concern or
should I just shave more and let it go
it is immature and there are some people
who are like weird about body hair and
then there are also people who are hairy
and I just like wouldn't say those two
people should be together but I don't
think this is something you need to
break up over but you don't want to
always be feeling self-conscious you
don't want to always be having to shave
your legs you don't want to have to get
laser because your weird boyfriend
doesn't like body hair no I mean like
leg hair who's even looking at your legs
like for him to notice that like he
really needs to grow up yeah but he's
like he's not he probably won't in any
you know timely fashion and you don't
want to always be self-conscious about
it
so I don't know what to tell you if you
really like conceptually like I just
don't feel like you should have to shave
your leg by way my hair grows F too but
then he's always like no but you're not
a hairy person like there are people who
are hairy and you're not a hairy person
no but my hair grows fast like if I need
to have like hairfree legs I got to
shave every two days for sure but like
even when your hair comes in it's like
probably thin and even if you're wearing
it's really not no you're not hairy you
don't know what it's like to be hairy I
mean neither do I but I just know that
people have got hairy problems yeah and
there's a difference of course between
being hairy and being someone who
Embraces hair which is not something I'm
ever going to do no no I mean if you
want this relationship to work and you
don't want him always like you don't
want to worry what he's thinking about
you like sure get lasered but I just
like don't like the idea of getting like
cosmetic procedures not at your own
accord not like on your own accord but
because but because like someone else is
making you feel
insecure yeah but then like I I would
want you to sit down with him and be
like listen [__] off y y you're being
IMM mature but then and maybe he would
shut up about it but then like you would
get in your head like every time you're
with him being like Oh my is he's
staring at my legs yeah yeah
no it's not good no it's not good I just
feel like you guys have like different
values on this one thing and it's like
weirdly going to keep coming
up
yeah like he should be with someone else
who doesn't like hair who's already
lasered right right maybe someone with
alopecia maybe because he's so extreme
like
okay no I like this kind like actually
bothers me and I'm going to say
something crazy I think you should break
up with him like for
real like it's a it's about a bigger
thing do you know what I mean no I agree
so like let's try and find other reasons
why the breakup is a good idea you know
what I mean like this is just like one
small moral it can't be just this if the
relationship is perfect otherwise stay
with him but I just know that it's not
no I know because this is emblematic of
larger issues agreed I'm loving the word
emblematic today you're emblematic no
you are
okay you ready for a third and final a
little bit longer ready Jackson turd I
really need your advice I'm a longtime
toaster firsttime writer I'm getting
married in September and I have some
family drama my mom and I are incredibly
close and when we lost my dad three
years ago we really leaned on each other
my mom has now started dating a guy and
that alone has been super painful but as
much as I selfishly want my mom to stay
home knit and be alone forever I do want
her to be happy I know no other man will
be a pom like my dad so I'm kind of
happy that she has someone to spend time
with the issue is my mom's boyfriend of
literally three months wants to come to
the wedding I've not yet met this man I
do not know this man she has brought it
up multiple times that she wants to
bring him and feels like she will be
quote alone at the wedding without him I
want her to have fun and support her
dating but I draw the line at her
bringing him it is already an extremely
sad situation with my dad not being able
to be there and adding this man being
there will make me too emotional on the
day be honest with me and let me know if
I'm a wench for not letting her bring
him I don't think you're a wench you're
entitled to your feelings there's a lot
at play here I but I don't think you can
see the situation because you're so in
it and you're so emot
so we're going to give you two outside
perspectives okay I think you should let
your mom bring him like she wants to
have a dancing partner I think her being
alone all night would make her sad and
just make her constantly aware that she
lost her husband meanwhile she has a
nice man who she gets along with and he
can't be there certainly don't have him
in pictures he shouldn't be acting like
he's you know Father of the Bride but
like she wants someone to to have on her
arm and I think that that's really fair
and it doesn't replace your dad and you
know and weddings are like really made
for couples yeah like like with the
dancing and just everything and and it's
her daughter's wedding and she'll never
feel more acutely aware of her
loneliness than if she's alone at your
at your wedding like yeah and it's like
you are getting married like you are
moving forward and if she should stay
alone because it'll make you feel better
right and there are people like it's
like okay if he brings if she brings the
boyfriend like that will make me sad if
she doesn't bring the boyfriend like
that will make her sad and I'm the type
of person that's like I'd rather should
her that sadness and deal with it like
I'd rather you be happy and me like not
get my way way I don't agree that it
like bringing the boyfriend would make
the toaster sad wouldn't the toaster but
wouldn't the toaster be sad seeing her
mom be sad and alone isn't that more sad
that's how like I would feel and
regardless of how you slice it like
there will be a a gap you know on the
day like that your dad he's not going to
be there no matter what at least let
your mom have a little bit of Joy like
she's expressed that she wants him to be
there like I think she should have him
there
yeah I think absolutely this man needs
to come I don't think your feelings are
totally valid but you're only really
seeing it through your lens of like your
experience your dad your wedding this
was also your mom's husband think about
the person you're marrying like that was
it for your mom I think like actually
I'll be honestly I'm not trying to be
mean I really will be disappointed in
you if you don't let your mom bring the
boyfriend you you have to yeah it's just
no matter how you SCE it your dad's not
going to be there I feel like you like
need to accept that and so if there's
going to be this person that you know is
going to spin your mom on the Dance
Floor all night great what You' rather
see you rather see her sitting alone
while you're living your best life and
on your happiest day of your life true
it's so true I think you need to have a
little bit um I feel like this happens
with grief sometimes like you're so
focused on your own grief that you can't
see out of it and you don't see how like
other people like yeah he was your dad
but he was your mom's husband you know
and that's that's a Val her experience
is valid too and if this is going to
make her feel better like you have I'm
sorry have to yeah you have to please
let me know if you let your mom bring
the boyfriend yeah oh and if you've
written into dear toasters in the last
couple of months weeks years whatever
and we've given you advice and you have
an update for us good bad ugly we don't
care write us an update don't leave us
hanging don't take our advice and like
not tell us what happened okay send the
update in the email title to Dear
toaster gmail.com by the way you are
going to be so busy on your wedding day
you won't even notice whether he's there
or not the only person who's going to
really notice is your mom yeah it's so
true
so that's that thank you guys so much
for writing into dear toaster and thank
you for listening to the toast the
millennial Morning Show where we deliver
the past five stories that you need to
know every Monday through Friday on
YouTube so if you're uh watching this on
YouTube [__] subscribe and give us
video a thumbs up and leave a comment
wow if you could have the toasters take
any one action subscribe on YouTube
subscribe on podcast follow us on
Instagram let's not get into our
personals because I don't want to I
don't want to fight with you but what
would you what's most surpris
priority it's one of the hardest
questions you've ever asked me I think I
would take a podcast
subscription
no you know what I would take become a
patron patron.com thast new content
drops all we actually dropped an episode
yesterday CL we didn't even talk about
it oh yeah we did we did we did a
podcast episode two days ago and it the
the premise for the episode was naggie
[__] wife where we were going to read
your naggie [__] wife submissions which
we did towards the end but we mostly
just like talked about ourselves and
what's going on with us I feel like we
hadn't done like a catch up in a while
so it's actually really nice to catch up
it kind of felt like what our podcast
episodes would sound like if you and I
did a weekly regular podcast just like
everybody else that wasn't like a pop
culture
show talking about our lives you're
talking about your apartment your
husband I was talking about my ankle um
I don't have time to go to the doctor so
if anyone could just like take a look at
my ankle Jack a lot of people think it's
broken think your ankle's broken would I
be able to walk if my ankle was broken
does it hurt when you walk not when I
walk specific like it's I'm aware of it
if I turn it in certain ways you have
just like a very minor fracture like in
your like it doesn't have to be
completely shattered listen I really I
don't have the time to go to a doctor
you have to go to like a citymd and just
get an x-ray can you look what is it
what do you think doctors please head
over to YouTube it's swollen it's a
little purple and yellow um is my ankle
broken and she had like she had snapped
it in a grassy field she like ankle I
twisted my ankle yeah yeah thank you um
sound also available sound off in the
comments is my ankle broken
we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcast can be found so that's
Spotify iTunes Stitch public radio I
radi cast box all the places listen to
podcast find to had a beautiful stuning
and wickedly talented we are hope you
guys have an amazing incredible
Wednesday hump day we are back in studio
tomorrow and we'll see you then I just
want to say the purpleness has go has
like really gone away it's more of a
yellow green does that mean that it
wasn't Broken Sound up in the comments
love you
bye